You forgot about my shower gun.
Who could have predicted that by
subsidizing the blob and
forgiving student blob, we'd somehow
create more blob.
Didn't you guys write a blob
reduction ac?.
Ma'am. This neighborhood's not zoned
for an Airbnb.
So yeah.
Graveyard gun.
You know, you don't need to wear
that anymore, right?
Stay inside.
Behind locked doors for safety.
Awesome.
I've been waiting for this since
Y2K.
I've got six months worth of
rations, a crisis guard and a backup
generator, a water filtration kit,
19 guns and a shit ton of
ammunition. Yes, now I can save
myself and all my.
Seeking human victims.
Friends.
It's hard for us here to believe
what we're reporting to you, but it
does seem to be a fact.
Right for the last time, the hideous
stitched together monster isn't
Frankenstein.
It's the omnibus spending bill
and we're going to go get it.
Tonight, Lieutenant Governor John
Fetterman and Dr. Mehmet Oz face
to face. For the first and only
time, this
Pennsylvania U.S.
Senate Debate.
Honey they're going to access the
cameras without a warrant.
I'm taking them down.
We did it everybody out, we outlawed
charter schools.
Yeah. Let's hear it for our fearless
leader.
Eyewitnesses say they are ordinary
looking people. You don't need to
build a wall.
They're just coming here to pick
fruit.
Oh, you guys.
I said Burning Man.
Dammnit.
This movie really holds high.
We're going to need a bigger boat.
Good luck with the Jones Act, pal.
Are you under 18?
No.
Good. What's your name?
Why do you want to know my name?
So I can sign you up for Selective
Service.
Did you say?
Yeah, we're coming for girls too?
There it is. Seven years of
returns and receipts.
I heard they hired 87,000 more of
you bloodsuckers.
But this is a little on the nose.
How do you like it?
Bird gun!